let me go young man
the twine it
so high-level feed the Papa
assalamu alayka what i've met you like
were better care to brothers and sisters
and dear friends hope you guys are doing
well
obviously we're going to talk about what
this video is and what the purpose
behind it before get into that and
brother in one's going to be sharing
with us a verse in the quran and going
into the tafseer a bit from even kaffir
yeah so inshallah he's going to explain
to us in detail how to find the true
happiness that our hearts um for so
obviously this message is a brother
aleem as you guys know him you know he
likes his cars etc you know mashallah
you know he's got really nice cars you
know may Allah bless Monisha like that
wealth is for the good purpose of his
instead of a bad you know because
obviously Allah gives wealth to
everybody but it doesn't mean it's for
the good
so inshallah is for his good and his
family now brothers and sisters you need
to understand that every single one of
us are created in a way where we yearn
for something and some of us think that
happiness lies with cars money girls
houses whatever it may be and personally
myself coming back from that jahiliyyah
days this is what I used to search for
and I thought this was happiness and I
did chase it only that I lost want Allah
guided me and made me realize that these
kind of things will never make you happy
it just it just won't make you happy you
know even though I didn't drive as much
as nice cars as brother I leave you know
I had my little walk so Corsa but again
I did to her you know it still it did
not make me happy no matter what it was
no matter what cut so obviously that's
why me and brother in man I spoke to me
the morning and I said a key you know I
saw the Instagram of the brother and he
looked like he's a bit upset and you
know we all go through these stages in
life as well so I thought you know let's
do a brotherly message because obviously
you need to understand your own was they
were Muslims you get it you know if you
know if you're going through something
we should be there to help you
insha'Allah so I discussed with
manimaran
you know when from the Quran found some
amazing verses so that's about it from
me
initial brother Allen this is for you
inshallah I keep me Allah bless you in
sha Allah I'm gonna give it straight to
brother in man he's going to share with
you the iron the Quran inshallah hamdu
lillah wa salatu was-salam where I'd out
of through today he's on the love where
I leave for Silla my bad
Salaam alaikum brother I want to talk to
you directly in Charlotte to Adam and he
always does a little bit myself I kick
him basically first and foremost this is
not coming from a place of hate in any
way shape or form it's coming from a
sincere place the Prophet SAW Allah Ali
Salim said LD and I'm also you have
this religion is advice so I'm just
coming at you from perspective of
brother I see you know on an Instagram
he was down you're a bit confused I
don't really have focus in your life you
said you're going through the depression
and I just want to reach out to you and
just share something with you that I'm
confident if you listen to me bro it
will give you that clarity and eradicate
that depression it will show you how to
rather eradicate that depression in
surah al-e-imran Allah subhana WA Ta'ala
says are all to be let him in a shape
and a regime a lot talks about a group
of things that human beings naturally
desire understand it's natural it's not
bad it's not wrong to desire any of
these things and all those affirming
that for us so some of these things and
this is the main thing that we really do
desire loss denied in a society mean and
I said well Benina well an ethereal one
parity minute ahead you wanted Lottie
well Halen Musa wallet even an army will
have what is that we have placed inside
of the human being
cigarette unless inside humans the
desire for women let's be real I mean
men like women women like men right you
desire each other it's like one of the
biggest desires out there right then
upon that almost panel analysis also the
holding of golden silver now gold and
silver that time tell us means money
cash you like money a key that was their
currency we need to start in please
but then unless is something interesting
he said hey little moves so well Matty
he said and very fully bred horses like
topper arranged horses my brother and
sisters by extension we're listening
what is the equivalent of full nice
bread horses today
could you get horses then you get the
fully bread ones right Ferraris maybe
exactly read Camus eggs exactly they
remember horses were a means of
transport for them the the ones that
Allah is talking about in this ayah he
didn't move sublimity these are the ones
that are the super cars of today and
then unless it well and a me one-half
which is basically today's equivalent of
business is nine-to-five a good job and
a nice income a nice career in other
words so a view on Las affirming for us
that he put along as he he did this he
put inside you and me the desire for
women that
I for wealth the desire for nice cars
and a really good career but then
unlicensed I only come at Aaron Hyatt in
dunya now listen this is the one the one
who himself gave this inside of you now
told you about it then he come at our
AIT dunya you know what this is this is
just from the provision of this world in
life pennies yes exactly uh yeah I was
in this district all of this these big
we made cause all these things it's just
it's just the worldly life but with
Allah in the law yes we my AB but what
Allah has for you with him that's not in
this world what Allah has for you with
him
it's even better if I was selling phones
you came to me to acquire this phone and
I told you bro I made this phone I sell
this phone I know this phone guess what
it's a rubbish phone are you gonna buy
it no because the one who created the
phone the manufacturer of the phone is
tell you after this phone is a waste of
time don't purchase this phone you're
gonna be right for you ok I mean you're
losing business but I'm not about to buy
this phone the same actually don't want
to create in this F who created the
woman who create this this super
powerful rides and cause he create I
mind that manufactured is right you
created welcome gives us wealth
businesses gave us these opportunities
in setting tell you at the end day you
know what it's not even worth a penny to
me we can have women money cause it's
fine you can have a night obviously as a
wife not like women on the street or
whether I've you but the thing is you
have to have these things in balance you
have to have the but something else as
well they can't be your objective they
could be a minstrel as an objective but
then okay they can't be the show reason
and purpose for which you live now I'm
not going to leave you hang in there bro
and I want you to and I want to explain
to you something right so what I want to
do is I want to think into the next ayah
because in the next ayah allah subhanaw
taala what he does is he told you that
which is better in the hostile vibe
remember that's which would allies
better worid y no me no ma and unless
you know what else is better is earning
Allah's pleasure but you know when you
work and spend your entire life trying
to accomplish something and then you
look towards those
who you look up to and respect the most
for their approval like your parents for
example if your parents come to you tell
you I am displeased and disappointed
that has but if your parents and if they
are the ones that really mean the world
to you and they say you know what my son
I'm pleased with you
you can have nothing you could have just
just brought home a little drawing you
did at school in year 9 they told ya
that will make you feel like you're on
top of the world or it will mean Allah
is when Allah is pleased with you that
that is real pleasure that is real
happiness now the question comes what is
the relationship between having a
spiritual relationship with Allah and
mine and your happiness well it comes
back down to mining your essence you see
Allah mentioned that these things these
things in the previous verse money women
cause they put this pleasure inside of
us it's because they're not bad no one
saying is bad to have really nice things
let's go Allah put that desire in you
and the reason he did that in us was
because that it feeds our body remember
we're made from two components we're
made from our soul and we made from our
body sometimes we act like we're just a
body not so the body is a material thing
so it requires material things in order
to feed it right it needs food it needs
the body called me like actually fed you
know with things that are immaterial you
need to put material tangible fruit in
your belly right to feed you but notice
that the body where did it come from
it came from the ground cuz I'm not
crazy - Adam our Father I do set up from
the dirt that came from the ground now
we feed our bodies nice companies are
healthy but guess what we don't feed and
we deprive and we starve we don't feed
our soul our souls are starving and
hungry and you know when you say I'm
feeding an emptiness inside you your
body is not feeling an emptiness your
body is healthy bye brother
but it's your heart it's your soul your
soul is feeling weak the depression is a
result of having a
disconnection with how to actually feed
and nourish your soul so you've got a
very hungry soul right now bro now in
order and why I promise you my brother
the only way to get over this void you
feel in your life is to now fill that
sword up with healthy things now where
does the food for the Soul come from
which is a very rational question to ask
well it comes from the same place the
song came from the same way the food for
the body came from what the pony comes
from the food for the soul comes from
wither so came from where did this all
come from among the come on of avoir it
so came from Allah Allah gave his Nestle
so guess for the food for the Soul comes
from it also comes from what Allah gave
us what did I lie give us unlike Eve his
daughter and I Allah gave this direct
speech it came from above desert I gave
us the poor and he gave us something
that is from last night's speech and the
way that we implement the poor and the
very basic way is through the five daily
prayers so anything that we place our
happiness and does desires it whether
they be women cause anything from those
from that verse women money wealth cause
businesses these things will eventually
go my profile so if they are happiness
is based on a happiness will go but
guess what if our happiness is based on
Allah even if these things leave us and
our body is to sobbing the fact that our
soul is still happy it's connected to
something that's everlasting our
happiness will be everlasting ok as you
heard from brother in my emotionally
explained in a beautiful way and also
I'm just going to share two verses in
the Quran from you where others want
Allah says if you forget my remembrance
indeed you will have a depressed life
and it's close to everybody not just you
actually me everybody Allah says only
with the memories of your Lord does your
hearts find peace so actually this is
the message to us I don't want to long
get out inshallah the battery's dying on
the mic anyway so we're shutting out for
you each other guys please share this
with the brothers pages we want to get
through to in facebook I tried messaging
him I don't know if he got back to me
but obviously try to get this message
out to him and actually you know my
facebook you know in Milan's Facebook
tower man you can message him you can
message me Ali da WA well whoever you
want at least I've total opportunity
versus Twitter you can check him on
Twitter key whatever you want it shadow
just get in contact with us we can come
to you if you want as
we can sit down and talk and inshallah
you know we can learn stuff from you you
can we can you know learn about cars
from us a lot maybe more maybe more
installer and you can learn from us from
different stuff initially will be nice
as brothers coming down and sitting down
that's about it for me okay I'm keep
looking at the mic because it's about to
die assalamu alaikum it's way way better
here too may Allah's mercy and blessings
be upon you may Allah grant you Janaki
that's a body from us salam alayka wa
rahamtullah take
you